it's no secret that Deadpool is making a  ton of money not bad for an r-rated  comic movie but does that mean the door  is open for more r-rated takes on our  favorite superheroes apparently the  upcoming x-force movie and Wolverine  three are aiming for it Simon Kinberg  oversees the x-men universe for Fox he  spoke to Collider about the movies  saying I think there are some stories  that could be r-rated I don't know what  they are I mean I think the main line  x-men movies have their own tone which  is a more operatic tone it's more  dramatic it's more PG 13 in a way  x-force I could see being rated R and  who knows a catalog at new york toy fair  listed wolverine 3 for a summer 2017  launch with an anticipated are reading  as for x-force all we know is that a  movie is happening if Fox announces more  you'll hear about it from gamespot